hello reject nation it's Greg Alva here
look who's back on the channel Stacy Oh
Howard you can follow Stacy Oh Howard at
Instagram and Twitter and she is of
course on the YouTube channel miss
movies every Wednesday a livestream
session would Bria and Chandler yes
indeed how are you Stacy I am a doing
just fine when did you get this haircut
I got this like two weeks ago I want to
say I cut like four inches off and I
want to say that I cut out like a bad
ex-boyfriend from my life you know how
you know getting a new haircut in an
outfit makes you feel good like I feel
like a new woman with this but you're
not going through a breakup no I'm not
but it's just I'm likening it to that
okay it's like um it's like I've become
a mom but I don't have a kid yet ah you
know like I just I'm cutting the
[ __ ] out and also physically cutting
my hair and I really like it I haven't
had this short ever I don't think oh
well it looks fantastic
Thanks you look great - your hair's very
long yeah
that's not intentional can I can I yeah
yeah this is like yeah look it goes
pretty far I could bite my hair have you
straightened it yeah I look like an
anime character
speaking of cartoon characters they
released like a 30-second clip of
Justice League a deleted scene what I
know I hope so I hope to god I hope it's
like someone brushing his moustache was
originally gonna be the movie all right
well it's called black suit I'm sure
there's not much in here but people have
requested it
and I only live to honor people's
requests hatred mayonnaise to strangers
so there's a bunch of vaginas right
there yeah
I'll always see your vaginas things I'm
trying to black there it is there's the
black Superman I think it's there's no
[ __ ]
that's it that's all we get for this
awesome deleted to see people requested
but damn I heard I actually heard there
was a lot of scenes they shot with him
wearing the black suit before Joss
Whedon stepped in they had like a whole
other movie plan and how to handle
Superman in this whole other edition no
we don't need that I mean this black
suit looks like it would have been sexy
though man henry cavill in that suit he
went super really interesting to see
where it would have gone but well we
won't know we'll never know why they're
saving it for the next I mean they're
saying they're gonna show deleted scenes
on here and there's been so many people
demanding the extended cut and like all
the petitions and stuff oh yeah so I'm
wondering if this is just a tease at the
fact that they're gonna give us a bunch
of deleted scenes because I know them
they did like Suicide Squad they only
cut out like 10 minutes or something and
that was what's in the extended cut and
BBS only had like 10 or 15-minute extras
as well but Justice League I've heard
like an hour of that movie was trimmed
out so I would love it if they if we can
get some scenes with him in the Superman
suit I think that's the happy medium to
meeting fans halfway because fans have
been wanting the extended cut and said
if you can't re edit a whole movie then
at least give us the deleted scenes like
show some scenes where he's rockin the
Black Sea I just feel I'm very
conflicted about extended cuts and extra
scenes okay because I mean I feel like a
movie you like you get the one movie you
get the one chance and if people don't
like it you didn't make a good movie
didn't hit in theaters like I'm just
old-school like that you know I'm not
like a I hate all that like there's
teaser posters and teaser trailers know
this I'm like no one trailer and you get
the one movie and you have your one shot
this is [ __ ] Hollywood okay and there
are kids out there on the street trying
to make it every day so I don't want to
give all these directors a bunch of
chances to like oh no but it was
actually this and this is the story I
wanted and no you have one chance so you
didn't even want the deleted scene oh
wow what did you like just asleep you're
like wow this would have been so much
cooler to have because I see
they should put it back it was so great
in the movie cuz this scene looks cool
to me I'm sure the full version of this
scene was probably really cool it
absolutely does look cool maybe Justice
League would have been in a different
movie and I would have liked it more I
didn't hate it but I maybe I what I
liked more police was in there but guess
what they didn't do that make decisions
at the time well I'm sorry I showed you
these 30 seconds chance to blow gosh
well guys good I'm glad you got to say
something positive towards this well
guys that's not what you can say about
30 seconds of a Stacey found a way to do
it thanks thank you for being here you
guys can subscribe to the real rejects
click that notification bell tell me if
you're gonna buy Justice League on
blu-ray
most importantly though follow Stacey Oh
Howard on Instagram and Twitter no II
know I just why yeah just know that I
follow her too and I like every PO she
posts he does I don't like the bikini
photos though cuz I don't want to be a
creep although those are the only ones
that all my friends look at okay good to
know
good to know yeah that's a Collider
videos see you again